bloggers journalists I think bloggers
are bloggers and there are good ones and
there are lousy ones you know Andrew
Sullivan is a really good blogger he has
four or five issues he's passionate
about he has a couple of good webby
ideas like readers sending in pictures
out their windows he's good at it
there are political blogs that are good
at it there are specialty blogs that are
good at it
are there a lot of bloggers who are
doing that you and I understand to be
the conventional reporting work of a Bob
Woodward or a Seymour Hersh or Jane May
or whatever not a lot no that's
expensive consuming and it's not Bloggie
you can't do it five six times a day on
the other hand joshua mika marshall does
a very good job by continually linking
to things that he thinks that you should
be as obsessed with us he is and what
you're reading with him is a kind of
pool you're staying with a certain
political sensibility it's interesting
so to me the question is not are they
journalist not journalist it's just
obviously a new form a different form
and they're good ones and they're bad
one